Georgia voters are sending the states
first Republican woman to Congress after
a closely watched special election karen
handel received nearly 52% of the vote
defeating John Asaf by almost three
percent President Trump last night
tweeted his congratulations to handle
for her quote big win mark Strassmann is
at her campaign headquarters north of
Atlanta
mark good morning good morning karen
handel one this special election
comfortably in what was the most
expensive house race in history both
sides spent more than 56 million dollars
but the seat of this affluent educated
district will stay Republican
special thanks to the President of the
United States over here
karen handel celebrated her new job by
thanking president Trump Tuesday night
but it's the president who may be the
night's biggest winner on Twitter he
took a victory lap for those that want
to make America great again my promise
is to work every single day relentlessly
to make our state and this country a
better place this House seat has been in
Republican hands since Newt Gingrich was
elected nearly 40 years ago but
Democrats sensed an opening thanks in
part to president Trump's low approval
ratings the fight goes on handles
opponent 30 year-old John Asaf raised
more than 23 million dollars in his
concession speech he looked to the
future of the Democratic Party this is
not the outcome any of us were hoping
for but this is the beginning of
something much bigger than us CBS News
elections and surveys director Anthony
salvato says the result could bolster
the president's legislative priorities
patterns tell you that Republicans came
out and if Donald Trump was a factor
that they were not ready to abandon
their support for him or at least
sending somebody else in Washington to
to go his way to vote his way last night
handle had a message for congressional
Republicans we have a lot of work to do
a lot of problems that we need to solve
we need to finish the drill in health
care
and that message was hardly lost on
Republicans watching in Washington
relieved to have kept the seat for
national Democrats this loss means more
soul-searching
they really hope suburban voters here
would send President Trump a different
message Thank You Marv